[Music]
madman is unusual in it terrific acting
and great writing but it is changing
it's having an impact on fashion which
few shows are able to do Mad Men this
show but few others they get you in
these outfits you have said that they
make they have you where the actual
undergarments from the 1960s oh yeah
everything's incredibly authentic and
and meticulous we have the full
undergarments and then the slips and
then the thing over that and it's um
it's a little bit of work to get dressed
yeah
and you've said I've heard that you've
said that this is it affects the way you
walk you have a very distinctive walk on
Mad Men and that you're helped a little
bit by well you put these things and
they sort of make you stand really
upright right and your body sort of just
naturally moves a certain way and so I
always thought that's what made this
sort of walk happen is you put this
undergarments on in this tight dress and
my husband teases me and says I walk
like that at home as well but this
change it to the undergarment it's
changing the way you walk yeah do you
like the fashion for men because I
thought you know you look at that show
and I think yeah the thin ties the the
leaner cut suits it's a cool look do you
like that I love it it's really caught
on I think a lot of men are dressing
like that but I wish men would wear more
hats cuz I really love the fedoras that
the guys wear on the show I think it's
really striking do you like fake I think
three few guys can pull off a hat like
that my husband wears it and he's got
this little one that he got the other
day and he looks like Columbo when he
wears it it's really good but he looks
like an old an old-fashioned movie star
in it I don't like that like I think you
have to have I mean like I say you have
to have a guys to have confidence in
there been times where people have I've
never wear hats and every now and then
someone you know why would you cover
that up
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you
there's nothing that will cover this out
my hair like fight it off no but yeah I
put on a hat like that I look like a kid
trying to pretend to be a news reporter
you know I don't have a real certain
yeah you have to own it I have a ton of
hats and I'd love to wear them and it's
easier in a city like New York you're
walking around on the street here you're
getting your car you've got your big hat
on and you're sort of feel a little
awkward yeah it's it's hard to do it
naturally here of course Mad Men one of
those shows it the the new season just
started after a long hiatus everybody
very excited about it and then of course
in the opening in the opening episode
there was a scene that everyone's
talking about
which is that I want to make sure I say
the bazoo the bazoombas ubi song yeah
I'm always saying it wrong the zubi zubi
zubi song where we're Don's new wife
sings this song and I swear to god it
was one of those situations where the
next day everybody was singing that song
I didn't know that yeah I've known that
song for years I love that song and
people had never heard of it I was
surprised and and I was just excited to
see guys like oh dae-su I love it I had
I had never heard me I'm weird for no no
no no it's I guess it's a French song
from I believe the early sixties a
French pop song and it was a you know
you guys kind of revived it in this one
scene where Dawn's wife new wife is
singing it to him at a party and someone
on YouTube made this great clip that
that actually uses some footage I
believe of Jean Claude Van Damme and
it's it's really fun we have it right
here let's take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
like everything
[Laughter]